neues aus china oder wie wir sie nennen
das land der untergehenden
menschenrechte seit dieser woche wissen
sie ist ganz klar in der provinz
xingjiang werden über eine million
uiguren in umerziehungslager interniert
und überwacht um ihnen ihre kultur und
religion abzugewöhnen absoluter horror
und der deutsche volkswagen-konzern
unterhält mitten in dieser größe provinz
ein werk aber das ist ja der vorteil als
vw sein image ist musste der wegen sowas
keinen kopf mehr machen
[Musik]
serdar somuncu sagt einfach mal danke
danke volkswagen was ihr für die deutsch
chinesische freundschaft leistet ist mit
geld gar nicht zu bezahlen obwohl wird
ja bezahlt daran erkennt man wahre
freunde in zeiten der not wenn rauskommt
dass du über eine million menschen in
lager stößt das dann so eine firma wie
vw sagt und egal was die anderen sagen
wir finden nicht weiter dürfte der vw
bus im april bitte sofort den blöden
slogan ändern statt das auto das kann
doch wohl nicht euer ernst sein bald
baut vw in xing gang übrigens den neuen
golf acht kostbarkeiten der hat ein
intelligentes abs system das bremst
nichts wenn ein uigure auf die straße
geht alles kein einzelfall
siemens hat in derselben provinz eine
filiale und kooperiert mit dem
staatsunternehmen ctc das laut human
rights watch für die polizei von xin
yang ein überwachungs system entwickelt
mit dem nicht vertrauenswürdige personen
identifiziert werden
in sowas sind wir deutschen einfach
spitze oder lufthansa auf druck aus
peking nennen die taiwan nur noch taiwan
china damit man weiß wem das gehört
deutschland land der dichter und
arschkriecher wussten sie eigentlich
dass unsere bundeswehr regelmäßig
chinesische offiziere schuld kein witz
wobei ich mich schon fragen was bitte
kann die mächtige chinesische armee von
der bundeswehr lärmen flugzeuge der
bundeswehr haben in den vergangenen 20
jahren
100 mal während des flugs teile verloren
flugzeuge die sich während des flugs
auflösen
das können wirklich nur ihr kleiner tipp
liebe chinesen wenn ihr lernen wollt wie
man eine armee verschrottet macht doch
lieber ein praktikum bei den ludolfs
selber summe und you sagt hans de
schreibt über die heute show ihr seid
die richtigen links [ __ ] besonders
welke die stradivari unter den
arschgeigen bei euch smileys
freudentränen freudentränen freundin
trennen freund rennkurs mit herz vielen
dank für ihr freundliches feedback für
ein exklusives geigensolo von oliver
welke
abonnieren sie den kanal